oh
my God
let me share with you my story
knowing this truth will change your life
forever this Dimension is not the only
one there is
there are other beings out there
that exist that are real that's
influencing this physical world but you
just can't see it the entertainment
industry is trying to change the truth
this is the real battle between truth
and lies
yeah
[Music]
demons do not stand a chance against God
you need to know that demons are real
knowing this truth will change your life
forever I will explain how it will
change your life forever as we continue
with this video
now you might be asking me Daniel how do
you know how do you know demons are real
come on
I know because I grew up with it I know
for a fact that demons are ill that
angels are real and then God is real the
devil yeah he's real as well I'll tell
you my experience in just a bit first
you need to understand this this
physical reality that you know or
experience with your senses is not all
there is your body is only a vessel of
some sort for your soul this Dimension
is not the only one there is now think
about it you have never ever physically
seen your own soul I mean when you look
in the mirror you just see your body
right but you don't see your soul
when you look at other people
you know they have souls but you don't
see it you just see their physical eyes
in the same way there are other beings
out there
that exist that are real that's
influencing this physical world but you
just can't see it
just like there are other things that
you cannot see like win you cannot see
wind physically
but you see its effects on the trees and
the water
the same goes for sound you cannot see
sound physically but you can hear it and
you can see the effects of it
[Music]
now have you ever seen people do
occultic practices or rituals
how about Satanic rituals or demon
possession
it is all very real and also very
dangerous
now let's move a step back let's use
some lighter examples
have you ever felt that when you go to
bed when you sleep that something is
pressing you down very hard
and whatever you do you can't get loose
it just presses you down you feel this
this evil is like this thing pressing
you down
or have you gone to church and you see
some women or men suddenly just start to
blaspheme God in the middle of a church
service but they don't look normal they
have these big eyes
and it doesn't blink and it doesn't look
like them
and when they scream or speak it also
sounds very very strange
need to know
life is a lot more than you think it is
we most people just know about the three
spatial Dimensions right and some who
believe in string theory they say there
might be 11 different dimensions I don't
know how many there are but I do know
God created everything including time
space and matter and he is not limited
by his creation just like the guys who
created the TV radio or computer does
not live inside of it there's a whole
spiritual world that you do not even
know about angels demons and God himself
the devil and millions of demons who are
following him are trying to destroy
human beings their souls because they
know that their time is limited and the
evidence
is everywhere if you just look let's
first start at
satanism
satanists are everywhere in every
continent and they have order a certain
group on every continent these are
people who call on demons to come into
them worse being Satan and doing sick
rituals
many of these people are living among
you controlling big corporations trying
to control world events deceiving
millions of people with lies doing
Satan's bidding and Jesus said to these
type of people in John 8 44 you are of
your father the devil and your will is
to do your father's desires he was a
murderer from the beginning and does not
stand in the truth because there is no
truth in him when he lies he speaks out
of his own character for he is a liar
and the father of Lies
this is the real battle between truth
and lies between light and dark good and
evil we are in this battle whether you
like it or not that is the truth you
know that Christians millions of
Christians around the world are praying
for peace in the world and satanists
they are doing the exact opposite doing
Satan's bidding and trying to bring
Darkness over this world pain and
suffering destroying thousands of lives
working behind the scenes so you don't
even realize it
one Peter 5 8 says be sober minded Be
watchful your adversary the devil prowls
around like a roaring lion seeking
someone to devour Satan's biggest lie is
trying to convince you that he or God
does not exist he doesn't want you to
believe that God exists because that
means that you can do whatever you want
you can continue to live in sin because
there will be no consequence so you can
continue to live in sin to lie steal
rape murder and pedophiles can do what
pedophiles do you know people ask what
is wrong with the world this is what is
wrong with the world people choosing to
live in darkness choosing to create pain
and suffering for other people because
of their sin 2 Corinthians 4 verse 4
says in their case the God of this world
has blinded the minds of the unbelievers
to keep them from seeing the light of
the Gospel of the glory of Christ who is
the image of God
so Satan is like the God of this evil
world
small G not capital G
he brings forth all kinds of evil
while all the good things come from
above from God James 1 17 says every
good gift and every perfect gift is from
above coming down from the Father of
Lights with whom there is no variation
or Shadow due to change
now with that in mind let me share with
you my story and this is the truth
most of you who know me from five years
ago when I started the channel you know
that I'm always honest in my videos
and so don't think that this is some
strange fantasy story this is my life
it is normal for me my father was a
preacher
and he freed many people who were demon
possessed and the last time that I went
with him to help someone who was
demon-possessed I was in my late 20s my
father passed on to eternal life just a
few years ago from cancer
now while I grew up I saw and heard the
strangest things
he started to get more and more when
people who were in Satanism came to my
dad for help because they realized that
my dad could help them and so it just
got more and more and more kind of worse
in a sense but I'll explain a little bit
more as I continue with the story let me
give you some examples
I remember waking up and we were
supposed to go to school and a carriage
door garage door is always locked and we
opened it up and it was just the satanic
marks all over the walls and I remember
this clear as day
there were so many of those circles with
the Stars in them and it is impossible
for someone to have gone in there over
the night because it was always locked
so these kind of things and there were
many of those examples always happen
another time there was a woman who was
part of Satanism my dad prayed for her
and uh she's just sitting and saying
there's a black car in front they went
and checked and there was a black car in
the front and there were other satanists
sitting in that car praying against what
we were doing so they were spiritual
warfare
another time one lady was sitting in
church and demons manifested in her as
she was sitting her family was there as
well and her husband and she just
suddenly slapped grabbed kind of his leg
and screamed and everybody looked and
this lady the demons in her manifested
in the six men could not even hold her
but they prayed and took her outside and
they delivered her and she's still free
to this day they are still close friends
of mine demons went into her when she
was young when she played with those
bones in witchcraft when she went to a
sangoma here in South Africa sangama for
some of you don't know because you guys
are from all over the world um
which doctor would probably make sense
so they would use these bones to contact
the spirits or demons and also to read
the future so she was playing with these
kind of things and the demons entered
into her she asked God for forgiveness
they rebuked the demons they went and
she was free
she's still free today another example
is this couple
you know this was many years later I
think I was even my teen teenage years
there was a woman who loved her husband
very much her husband did these long
transport drives with trucks and she
missed him but every time he would come
home after these long Journeys she would
just I mean attack him and he didn't
know what was going on she didn't know
both of them were just new Christians
and so they came to my dad and said
something happened because we became
Christians and this is now happening it
never happened what's going on here
and so he said well he doesn't know if
this is something psychological
or if something else is going on but my
father has the gift of the sermon
so he said well let's pray so he took
both of them he started to pray and he
says in the name of Jesus Christ
we just ask that the Holy Spirit Will
Reveal to us what is going on here and
he was continuing to pray like that and
then suddenly the woman just suddenly
manifested and just pushed the husband
away so my father rebuked the demon to
go away so that he can talk to the woman
and and the woman said she could still
see a little bit of what was going on
and she saw that the the husband looked
different anyway to get to the bottom of
the story and to keep the story short he
talked to the demon again and the demon
said that the demon gate um received
access into the woman before they were
married and that was through
sexual intercourse with a Satanist
that's how the demon got access into her
so he talked to the woman again so he
rebuked the demon to go away and then he
talked to the woman and the woman had to
ask God for forgiveness so that's a
foothold because if if demons the only
way the demons can come into is when you
give them access and they have access
through sin and so you ask God to
forgive you of that sin and they don't
have that that foothold anymore
so anyway I said that's what she did and
he rebuked the demon the demon went away
and she is still free today
now another story this is the one who
took the most of my father's time this
woman was involved in Satanism she grew
up in she was called the wife of the
devil and she had many demons in her
this lady was trained and brought up
from a young age within Satanism and
went through many demonic rituals one
time when a demon manifested she ran out
of the house towards the nearest
graveyard and when they found her I mean
sorry I'm almost smiling about this
because I'm not fearful at all of these
kind of things but it was just strange
because he was sitting on the top of the
fence there of the graveyard like a
gargoyle sitting like this with eyes
really big not even blinking and so they
were just rebuked the devil and they
went home
I remember another example
but let me just explain this
my room and my brother's room were right
next to my father's study room so he
would go there and pray with people who
were demon-possessed so we heard all
these things all the time and we had we
would have conversations about it as
well because my dad said he wanted to
tell us about the troops that we know
it's better to educate your kids on
these things instead of just ignoring it
and then they grow up and they have no
clue what these things are anyway so I
remember even this one time my dad went
in to pray again and this lady just a
demon in her was standing there with a
knife ready to kill my dad and then my
dad just sat and said in the name of
Jesus Christ moved back in the name of
Jesus Christ I rebuke you and then later
when he talked to the lady of course the
demon couldn't kill him or do anything
the the lady said that there was a an
angel on the right side that was just
holding the arm so nothing could happen
there were many of these examples that
we grew up with now this lady the same
lady who wanted to kill my dad the same
one who went to the graveyard she was
called the wife of the devil now this is
one of the highest ranks in Satanism
that you can reach when you're at this
level when you've gone through all these
rituals it's not just that you have one
two or a few hundred demons in even
thousands you have millions of demons
inside of you and when she was normal
she was she was actually nice she was
going through this whole Deliverance
process and she always brought these
sweets that I that I used to love these
licorice sweets so whenever she would
come you know I remember I was never
scared I just look at this does he have
sweets yes he has sweets now run over
and ask for sweets so innocent I
remember my friend came over and visited
one time and
um
I'm not going to say his name but
he called his mom because he was afraid
but I never knew you see for me it was
strange going to visit my friend's house
and and maybe his parents would argue
and stuff because that would be strange
for me because my parents my dad never
raised his voice against my mom they
would never have these
anyway like like normal family sometimes
would just argue and stuff that didn't
happen at our house there was always
love God was always present and there
would be these
Wars of demons right with people who are
demon-possessed but the the most
important thing of my home was my dad
lived the way that he preached he was a
preacher that that just brought the
truth of scripture and people were safe
that was his Focus he didn't I mean
these demon possessions and and the
fights of these demons it was just it
was something that you had to do to Free
People
but the most important thing was
bringing them to Christ but let me just
go back to the story of the woman
so these so this woman called the wife
of the devil
um she had millions of demons in her and
so you have to rebuke and exercise the
the weaker demons and then a stronger
one takes over so you have these
different ranks just like in the army or
in the police you have different ranks
of strength of these demons and so the
stronger ones they take more time some
of them that's really strong it takes
fasting and prayer for example listen to
this story in the Bible
Mark 9 17 then one of the crowd answered
and said teacher I brought you my son
who has a mute spirit
that's a demon and wherever it seizes
him it throws him down he Foams at the
mouth remember this I'm going to talk
about this foaming of the mouth a little
bit later on it gnashes his teeth and
becomes rigid so I spoke to your
disciples that they should cast it out
but they could not he answered him and
said o faithless generation how long
shall I be with you how long shall I
bear with you bring him to me
then they brought him to him and when he
saw him immediately the spirit convulsed
him and he fell on the ground and
wallowed foaming at the mouth now these
signs of what is happening you know
foaming of the mouth convulsing these
things are important because you see
this in demon possession that we
experience even today verse 21 he asked
his father how long has this been
happening to him and he said from
childhood and often he has thrown him
both Into the Fire and into the water to
destroy him but if you can do anything
have compassion on us and help us Jesus
said to him if you can believe all
things are possible to him who believes
immediately the father of the child
cried out and said with tears Lord I
believe
when Jesus saw that the people came
running together he rebuked the unclean
Spirit saying to it deaf and dumb spirit
I command you come out of him and enter
him no more then the spirit Cried Out
convulsed him greatly and came out of
him and he became as one dead so that
many said he's dead
but Jesus took him by the hand and
lifted him up and he arose and when he
had come into the house his disciples
asked him privately why could we not
cast it out
now this is important to listen to his
answer so he said to them this kind can
come out by nothing but prayer and
fasting
you know it's so strange how some people
when you see movies in TV series they
use salt you know so demons can't go
over or they put the oil you know on
windows and door he's so stupid
nothing but Jesus Christ can protect you
put it on the the doors and the windows
and demons come through walls so it
doesn't matter they come through the
roof if they want to only the power of
Jesus Christ can protect you now through
the Bible stories we can see how to
fight demons in this story we see that a
demon can control a human being his body
and make him do strange things so he's
foaming at the mouth doing strange
things convulsing but also not that
alone but when Jesus sent the spirit out
we also saw exactly how that happened
the demon cried out convolves the boy
and came out of him and we also read
about the foaming of the mouth
now I'm going to show you actual footage
of what I have just talked about what
the Bible is talking about these bodily
signs the foaming of the mouth
this footage is from a few years back
when my father and his team prayed for a
woman who was demon-possessed
here we go
[Music]
coming
soon
you know
and this is not but you know
oh
the Bible is true and you can trust it
you don't have to be afraid God has all
the power and the devil doesn't want you
to know it he doesn't want you to even
think that God is real now let's look at
another example the Bible shows us an
example of a demon-possessed man with
thousands of demons in him just like
this woman had thousands of demons in
her this woman my dad and his team
prayed for
Mark 5 or 6 and when he saw Jesus from
afar he ran and fell down before him and
crying out with a loud voice he said
what have you to do with me Jesus Son of
the most high God I Adore You by God do
not torment me for he was saying to him
come out of the man you unclean spirit
and Jesus asked him what is your name he
replied my name is Legion for we are
many
let me give you another example there's
one time my dad and some of his team
members prayed for two different people
who were demon-possessed in the same
house in our house so the one was in the
um my father's study the one I told you
about and the other one was in the
bedroom and they were praying for the
one and this demon had this high pitched
scream that was oh just the worst cream
and they were praying and rebuking it to
go out and the moment it went out it
went into the other one it was screaming
in this one so the highest the same
high-pitched sound from this one was
going in this one and this person was
delivered from this demon but that demon
went into this one demons are not like
us yes they have personalities they have
different personalities and they have
different powers they are stronger than
humans and they can manipulate and
deceive people easily
and only a true reborn Christian
can cause demons out so if you're not a
Christian and you encounter demon
possession or a demon don't try to fight
them
if you do not know God if you do not
have a relationship with him if you do
not have his holy spirit in you because
that's the only way how we can fight
demons is through the spirit that is in
US
so if you don't know Jesus Christ if you
don't have a relationship with him don't
try to fight them
there were men in the Bible who tried
they tried to use the name of Jesus
Christ
and they failed miserably Acts 19 and
God was doing extraordinary Miracles by
the hands of Paul so that even
handkerchiefs or aprons that had touched
his skin were carried away to the sick
and their diseases left them and the
evil spirits came out of them then some
of the itinerant Jewish exorcists
undertook to invoke the name of the Lord
Jesus over those who had evil spirits
saying I assure you by the Jesus whom
Paul proclaims so the Apostle Paul when
he started to heal people and exercise
demons
he was starting to be well known in
certain areas and so other people Jewish
people try to copy him verse 13 then
some of the itinerant Jewish exorcists
undertook to invoke the name of the Lord
Jesus over those who had evil spirits
saying I heard you by the Jesus whom
Paul proclaims seven sons of a Jewish
high priest named skeva were doing this
but the evil spirit answered them Jesus
I know and Paul I recognize but who are
you
and the man in whom was the evil spirit
limped on them mastered all of them and
overpowered them so that they fled out
of that house naked and wounded
and this became known to all the
residents of Ephesus both Jews and
Greeks and fear fell upon them all and
the name of the Lord Jesus was extolled
also many of those who are now Believers
came confessing and divulging their
practices and a number of those who had
practiced magic Arts brought their books
together and burned them in the sight of
all
today the entertainment industry was
mostly controlled by evil
is trying to change the truth it is
trying to blame Christians showing that
it is Christians who are evil trying to
fight witches listen demons are real
they are evil and I want to use you toy
with you and at the end destroy you and
bring your soul into hell with them
so they have different tactics to do
this the first is just open direct
satanism
people who join Satanism worship Satan
and certain demons directly but then
there are other ways that looks better
to humans through occultic practices
they use different methods but it comes
from the same power from Satan from
these demons which doctors black magic
white magic fortune telling talking to
the dead and so forth some of you might
be saying ah people don't do that
anymore they don't do necromancy they
don't try to talk to deaf people of
course they do
a lot of people who do ancestor worship
in fact that is their religion a lot of
these people think that they talk to
their dead ancestors while in fact it's
actually demons pretending to be their
dead ancestors
we saw this a lot growing up here in
South Africa
a lot of these people have demons in
them my dad helped a lot of people who
were demon possessed because of their
African well some of them call it the
the culture well this is different this
is demonic
there's nothing wrong with different
cultures unless that type of thing that
you do in this culture
moves you in this area where you start
to worship demons through occultic
practices
I don't have a lot of time to go into
this in a lot of detail but this is also
how some people can do occultic
practices demons can do these things
through people and then these people
think they are special because they
think they have power demons work on the
sinful fleshly nature of humans where
humans want to be great better and
Powerful like a god
the old lie Satan told Eve to deceive
her he uses the same old tricks
let's take a look at astral projection
for example there's a demon review and a
demon somewhere else in the world and so
when you think that you're experiencing
these things or know what's happening in
another country yes it can actually be
in another country not just in a
different city so this one demon stays
with you but they can communicate with
each other distance is no problem the
other demon is in a different country
and this demon sends all this
information to this demon and this demon
can even not just tell you this
information he can let you experience it
as well for example you can see things
happening in Japan and then when you
wake up from the so-called actual
projection you call your friend in Japan
and tell him what you saw
and he says yes that's exactly what just
happened how do you know that's because
a demon told you or gave you that
experience you can even see a lot detail
witchcraft
sorcery necromancy and other people
going into mysticism spiritism chakras
and using crystals opening up your third
eye it's all satanic it is so easy for
demons to let you experience these
Supernatural experiences so that you
will feel special and different unique
oh wow I experienced this in other
people don't God says in Deuteronomy 18
verse 10 there shall not be found among
you anyone who burns his son or his
daughter as an offering anyone who
practices divination org tells fortunes
or interprets Omens or as sorcerer
now you probably have and will see a lot
of these things in movies just take
Doctor Strange for example where they
try to make you think that it is cool it
is not cool it is occultic it is demonic
there is no mysterious energy or power
there's only God angels and demons
and they have powers yes there's a big
spiritual battle
between Good and Evil and you need to
choose you cannot just stay in the
middle you need to pick a side because
if you're not choosing that means you're
not choosing good
which means if you're not choosing
you're actually choosing Darkness
and those of you who have a wrong view
of Christianity you need to move away
from this thought of Christianity it's
just about rules and laws and it's so
strict and these people are weird
because that's what entertainment wants
to show you as well that they are these
weird or cult weird people that's not
the truth at all well there might be
some strange people but they're not true
Christians even though they call
themselves Christians
so move away from this idea true
Christianity is about having a true
relationship with God himself
you look at the truth you accept the
truth and God himself changes you it
gives you new spiritual life
eternal life and you are a new creation
you see things differently you think
differently
once you are changed
you want to do good you want to love
other people you don't want to do the
Bad Evil things that you've done before
God he created you
he wants to be your father and he wants
you to be his child and it starts by
realizing that God is spirit and you can
only worship Him in spirit and in truth
so you need to ask him to open up your
spiritual eye so that you can see the
truth these things I'm talking about and
the things that I'm going to talk about
in the other videos as well Jesus says
in John 4 verse 24 God is spirit and
those who worship Him must Worship in
spirit and Truth
if you don't choose the light
if you stay in the darkness you know
what's going to happen deep inside of
you in your inner man you know what's
going to happen
if you are busy with occultic practices
I want to warn you
because I love you
because I care
if I didn't I would not have made this
video
demons don't care about you
they actually hate you and they want to
destroy you even if they deceive you and
give you Powers you think it is your own
you use it and you think wow this is
great I'm using these powers
it's always negative in the end I've
seen it believe me
they want to kill you
and bring you into hell they are very
clever they can even pretend to be
angels
you know a few months ago I received a
testimony of a game developer and he
said well he didn't really grow up
Christian and he received suddenly this
occultic Powers you know he would dream
and then he would see exactly what
happened in his dream it came true
and as he explored this a little bit
more
this thing appeared to him as a friend
and over years this this friend wanted
him to to let him inside of him and it
became worse and worse and worse he even
told him that he is the Holy Spirit
so he allowed it and he did many
occultic practices
this demon also helped him and
influenced him to go to Christians and
try to
laughs
to take them away from God whenever they
open up the Bible he would first tactic
was to just close the Bible because they
don't want to talk about the Bible if
you get a Christian away from the Bible
you have him because then he doesn't
focus on the truth anymore if you can
get him on just saying what he thinks in
his emotions or thoughts then he's not
in truth anymore anyway there's a deep
discussion I had with him
and for years he followed this demonic
spirit
and at the end he found Christ
you know people who helped him and
rebuked the spirit and he was delivered
and he's still free up until this day
the Bible says in 2 Corinthians 11 verse
14 and no wonder for even Satan
disguises himself as an angel of Light
now this is a message for those of you
who say that you are Christians and you
have some kind of Supernatural power and
you want to use that in the church
you need to test it first to see whether
it is from God or not because there are
also counterfeit Spirits counterfeit
gifts in the church yes demons
pretending to do the work of the Holy
Spirit
and by doing it
you can deceive a lot of people and push
them away from the gospel and it's been
happening over the church in his last
few decades a lot especially in the
hippoc charismatic churches being
slaying the Spirit fall in the spirit
drunk in the spirit 1 John 4 verse 1
says beloved do not believe every Spirit
but test the spirits to see whether they
are from God for many false prophets
have gone out into the world
now the lady who was called the wife of
the devil she first saw the devil
Lucifer as a handsome man only later she
saw him for what and who he truly is she
wanted to accept Jesus Christ as the
Lord and Savior my father helped her to
to get free of those demons and it took
a long time because she had millions in
her remember I said that they they have
certain ranks so the weaker ones they
manifest first and then you have to
rebuke them that go out and then the
stronger one takes over and so it goes
on on and on he's got to continue like
that until all the demons leave and if a
person accepts Jesus Christ you know
their soul is filled with God they
receive the Holy Spirit then look at
their their body as a house their house
is not empty God is in there before
there were demons now the demons are out
and God fills it so now the demons
cannot come back and live there again
because God protects that person the
Holy Spirit seals them
until the day of redemption now if that
person does not accept Jesus Christ as
Lord and Savior those demons
who go out they will get more demons and
come back and that person will be worse
off than before
in other words
if there's someone you know who are
demon-possessed
there's no way to help them unless they
accept Jesus Christ as their lord and
savior because only God can save her or
him if you are watching this video and
you might be demon-possessed then you
need to choose between light and dark
if you don't then you choose the dark
and you will stay there
Jesus said in Matthew 12 43
when the unclean Spirit has gone out of
a person it passes through waterless
places seeking rest but finds none then
it says I will return to my house from
which I came and when it comes it finds
the house empty swept and put in order
then it goes and brings with its seven
other Spirits more evil than itself and
they enter and dwell there and the last
state of that person is worse than the
first but if you're hearing this for the
first time all of this about demons you
know that they are real that they exist
and that you can have Demons Inside of
You
don't be afraid one thing I saw Time
After Time After Time
is how
God help the person
the demons couldn't do anything
God is Victorious God is stronger God is
Almighty yes the the
devil is mighty and somebody the fallen
angels are Mighty but remember they are
just Fallen Angels God is God
he created the whole universe time
matters space everything you
and he's not limited by it is God
and he loves you
demons do not stand a chance against God
or against reborn Christians
who have the Holy Spirit God's spirit in
them James 4 7 says submit yourselves
therefore to God resist the devil and he
will flee from you
and Luke 10 19 says behold I have given
you authority to tread on serpents and
scorpions and over all the power of the
enemy and nothing shall hurt you
when a true reborn Christian prays for
someone who are demon possessed through
the power of the holy spirit that person
is freed forever and they are never
again the same they don't have those
problems
there are some whackers out there who
say that everything is demonic no there
are psychological problems people with
health problems but demons can also
cause psychological problems and health
problems it doesn't mean that everything
that's now a problem is because of
demons no
now I studied psychology and let me tell
you demon possession is very different
from people who have psychological
problems
people who have psychological problems
you can deal with that in a different
way but people who are possessed by
demons you can only deal with that with
the power of God there's no other way
and when you do deal with it even if
they have a psychological problem or
something else like the mute boy that we
read in scripture if the demon goes out
that problem goes out as well and that
person never have that same issue again
they are freed from it
my father prayed for a woman who suffers
from continuous blood flow for years in
the Free State here in South Africa and
it was a demon that caused it they
didn't know she went to doctors and
everything nobody knew getting depressed
so my father went prayed for her and it
was a demon so he rebuked the demon
demon went out and she was freed she
never had that health issue again
now apart from demon possession if
someone has some kind of health issue
God can also heal that if it is his will
look at this Matthew 9 verse 20. and
behold a woman who had suffered from a
discharge of blood for 12 years came up
behind him and touched The Fringe of His
Garment for she said to herself if I
only touch His Garment I will be made
well Jesus turned and seeing her he said
take heart daughter your faith has made
you well and instantly the woman was
made well life is more than what you
think it is
is a lot more than just this physical
world and it is time to open up your
eyes
to the spiritual world around you
demons are real
angels are real and God is real as well
and God is the judge of the world
you only live on this world
like that you're a vapor the one day
you're here the next you are gone but
the decision that you make on this Earth
will determine where you will go for all
eternity and God will judge you will
judge me he will judge you for every
action for every word every careless
word that you've spoken Matthew 12 36 I
tell you on the day of judgment people
will give account for every careless
word they speak
are you ready
what if you died today
where will you go
this is not a trick question this is
this is a question where I truthfully
care about your soul and I want you to
choose Christ so that I will be with you
in eternal life
and then we can talk about this strange
Earth or this short amount of time that
we lived here
because this is the amount of time we're
living here it's like a DOT at the end
of a sentence all the other words forms
a whole book and then the library and it
never stops that is eternal life because
it never stops
so while you're on this little Dot I
want to ask you and invite you to choose
Jesus Christ choose the light and if you
don't want to do it yet if you're still
uncertain you don't know who Jesus is
and why he had to die for your sins on
the cross
and watch the videos that's going to pop
up here at any moment now in the next
part of this series I'm going to answer
your questions on what about aliens and
what about other gods and other
religions it's going to be a very
interesting video that you don't want to
miss so make sure you subscribe and I'll
see you there and before you go always
remember life is short so don't waste
yours
cheers guys